the nevada spca is working hard to get  the word out and make sure your pets  also stay safe this holiday weekend july  4 the fourth can be a stressful day for  our furry friends and july  5th is one of the busiest days at  shelters across the country so  here's how to keep your pets safe as we  deal with all the noise on the fourth  make sure they are collared  microchipped so if they do get away and  run away because they're scared from the  noise  you do know where they are and they can  be found also keep cats and  dogs inside during the fireworks  celebrations calm them down maybe  put on a tv play some calming music to  drown  at out that noise sherry